[Applause]
welcome to the corridor crew what's up
guys we are doing a video that combines
the channel primitive technology and
last day on earth last day on earth is a
zombie survival horror game where you
craft your items to survive a zombie
apocalypse we are crafting a zombie meat
harvester out of sticks rocks hay grass
all that kind of primitive stuff it's
like a Rube Goldberg machine with VFX
we're gonna make it look like we just
took stick and rock and you use visual
effects to build different tools and
different items to use in the apocalypse
that's what we're doing so Jake
Christian and Sam are out on location
right now they are scouting the best
spot to shoot this video and hopefully
they can find a location today because
if they don't then we're kind of screwed
today
s-see village which turns out is it
great paintball and airsoft park if
you're in the Southern California area
we're not gonna be playing paintball and
airsoft we're gonna be building a
primitive campsite right over here it
was like just blow your pants you're
gonna have a tough time in those shorts
don't even trust me just like I did this
exercise on Thursday yeah son Scout
allows me to see the position of the Sun
throughout the day so you can see when
you're gonna be in shadow or when you're
gonna get direct sunlight it's really
helpful when you're scouting the fences
like this yeah and also we've in green
and grass and dirt so that's what the
fence is gonna look like
right
essentially gonna be like this was way
bigger so that I'll paint the big metal
cool and it's gonna be on Center stump
right right yeah yeah you know so the
next step is go down on the other side
of this map hogzilla's is about as clear
as it yet
yeah you just definitely would want to
drink it cuz it's all farm runoff you
want like a clear trail for the zombie
so when he explodes in the stakes we can
see them in like hitting the ground
clearly so we'll clear this out a little
bit more it's all being done in a single
campsite so things like where to put the
HUD - where to put this giant meat
harvester structure that we're gonna
build - where to put a campfire - where
to source the wood and how to get it
down here and how to build the fence
beforehand and transport it down here
and where to put the crew and where to
put the cars and where to put shade so
people can step out and have a sip of
water when they're hot and tired all of
that stuff is important in a location
like this - that way when you get there
you don't spend all your day trying to
shoot you spend your day shooting
walk over to one place
[Music]
right down into where every scoop know
that history
everything you need to be that
so we got a lashing anyway the plan is
super simple
you basically just make use you go
around over the top talking to the
camera then you go over and then you go
under go back around go up over around
and just repeat
we gonna lose every once in a while if
you want you can do some crossing I like
some crush lashing due to around this
way go around pull it tight of course
and then do cross this way
you should just go inside yeah hey let's
go on the inside because I think that's
about six feet
[Applause]
I thought we already autonomous
collected you fooling yourself
push it no they my guys pretty well did
there we go to turn zombies and the
steaks like this alright let's get out
of here oh dude the ants stopped Dennis
he saw
[Music]
cameras rolling fine on set
wait I'll say action tickly every single
shot we're gonna shoot today is gonna
require total silence because even the
plates peering stakes fly and hit the
ground and running through this so I got
myself a cool stereo audio setup here
where we've got two of these really
beautiful Sennheiser mics strapped up
top on my janky little ray going through
a zoom h4n which is my preamp which then
connected a line out which goes to the
stereo analog line in on the red giving
me nice awesome binaural stereo audio
baked into the footage it's gonna be
great be very immersive especially
looking at all these wide landscape
shots birds bees zombies Clint screaming
water water it's gonna sound beautiful
great the camera to me is aligned right
now
don't cross this line hit the ground
here I'm coming in I'm gonna climb this
ladder no flip-flops all right
but this note when you pick up that
stake yeah just just do quick do it a
little quickly I know you're chill here
but that was a very daring maneuvers
yeah definitely show that it was
required some exertion no no no no no
it's just I ruined it by snickering at
the end I just wanted a clean trunk
audio we can paste over my laughing next
to it like a little bit to get some like
weeds in action but floppy here we go
one sloppy take down no laughing that's
right no laughing rolling action
[Applause]
[Music]
all right like it's gonna be three two
one action for both of us I'm gonna I'm
gonna launch myself on the back of the
hut as soon as I launched myself like
you're out with the friggin with and I'm
excited let me check my shoes hey we're
doing a practical stunts I'm flying
through this wall held on by a couple of
little strings that you're Jake put into
place with or cutting those right now I
gotta watch my head though hit that
right in the back of the skull what's a
pro tip about doing stunts on your own
these safe as you can
this stunt that Clinton is about to
perform it's a one-time take he's gonna
Buster this Walt and the collapsing the
ceiling is coming straight out and then
to redo it we would have to redo
everything spurts making sure that's
great all right sweet things went well
today it seemed like we didn't have a
lot of shots of the shoot on paper but
the thing is when you start breaking
down each shot realize that each shot is
actually five shots because of just
magic tricks well magic tricks exactly
we needed five plates basically of every
shot that multiplied the amount of
setups we had to do pretty quickly but
today was awesome eaten cold steaks
flies going into my belly button we did
a ton of sick magic tricks in this video
when this main video drops on corridor
we're gonna break it down for you on the
corridor crew Channel we're gonna show
you how we went about doing all of these
special magic tricks make sure you are
subscribed because we didn't get a
toilet the script changed to where I'm
the one who got captured well oh man
dirt don't crack dude all the same stuff
still here oh you don't need a pretty
bad as empty and I'm there and we're
gonna get our plates basically this
thing moves